Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P here is a
caller complaining about the time
that we do the show each day.
Speaker 5: PJ would like to know why you
can't do your show same day in the afternoon
so that it's more up to date and that you're
not reporting yesterday's news period.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, um, we no matter what
time we do the show, someone has a problem with
it. We actually used to do the show later in the
day. We used to film more like three or 4:00,
and then it would go out by like seven or so. And
what that led to is that many of our affiliate
stations couldn't air it until the next day, and
the first YouTube clips would publish around seven
or eight, but then more of the clips wouldn't
publish until the next day. With the podcast,
people who go to the gym in the morning or after
two in the afternoon, more likely they would write
and they say, You know, David, I go to the gym at
three, four or five six. The podcast is an hour
until seven or eight, so I'm not hearing it until
a full 24 hours later. People didn't like that.
There's always some issue, but the bottom line
is as follows Think of all the platforms we're
producing for and genuinely to get the show
out the fastest. What we found is we record
in the very early afternoon, late morning, early
afternoon. The audio podcast is out by 2:30 p.m.
Eastern. Usually that's still 11:30 a.m. in the
West and that really feels pretty good without
dealing with this like starting to bleed over into
the next day thing. Remember also that as a member
you can get the full commercial free audio or
video feeds usually by like 3 p.m. Eastern. That's
noon on the West Coast. So that's the schedule I
get. It's not a perfect schedule for everybody.
We have some stations that say we'd like to run
at it too, but you don't get it to until 3:00. So
those stations have to run the show the next day.
We're doing the best we can given that we have an
audience across so many different time zones.
Usually it's a combination of stories from the
later half of the previous day and that morning. I
mean, on today's show, there's stuff that happened
this morning that is on the show. So I don't even
agree with the idea that we're like a day behind.
But certainly when Trump's Mar-A-Lago speech is
at 8:30 p.m., that's going to be on the next day's
show. It's sort of inevitable when Trump doesn't
get out of his arraignment until almost 4 p.m..
It's very tough to have that on that day's show.
We review it the next day. And one other thing
I'll say, it's not the end of the world to give
a little bit of space, particularly with stories
where you want to get as many of the details
included and correct in the show. So I feel pretty
okay with the schedule right now. Always open to
hearing thoughts from others. We've got a great
bonus show for you today. We'll talk about the Bud
Light boycott from the right wing. It's a wild,
wild one. We will talk about a new North Carolina
North Carolina lawmaker switching parties. And we
will talk about a judge ordering Stormy Daniels
to pay Trump another 120 grand in legal fees.
What is that about? Does it have anything to do
with the arrest from this week? No, it doesn't.
But we will talk about it on the bonus show sign
up at join Packman dot com to get instant access.